[Music]
so is this your first time in Berlin yes
well it's remarkable time to be here
wonderful music superb nightlife
marvelous restaurants you must try the
central coffee for a drink you'll need
it later
you remember mr. Bremer [ __ ] don't you
of course you do well he's very curious
what you're doing here in Berlin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to Berlin I'm David don't shoot
I've got your shoes I chose this life
and someday it's going to get me killed
but not today
[Music]
Lorraine brought on an expert in the
intelligence collection and have had to
come back
agent Gascoigne was killed last night
did you know him enough to say that he
had an atomic bomb of information and
find out who's hunting our operatives
and trust no one
[Music]
David person still content
welcome to Berlin hunting don't shoot
I've got your shoe yeah that was me from
the moment my feet touch the ground
never pass the plan was far just lying
I've lost the target from the thieves
would you know what this woman has been
following me he look like him saving
[Applause]
[Music]
so you made contact with the French
operator obviously 300 [ __ ] where the
charges
the clock is ticking and everyone you
get close to ends up dead someone set me
up someone from the inside now this only
ends one way
Maxie
my god I think I love you
that's too bad
[Music]
[Music]